good afternoon
i am brian rabbit acting assistant
attorney general for the department of
justice's criminal division
i'm joined today virtually by acting u.s
attorney seth ducharme
of the eastern district of new york and
assistant director bill sweeney
of the fbi stephanie avakian director of
the enforcement division at the u.s
securities and exchange commission
and assistant general counsel for
enforcement jason gonzalez of the
federal reserve board
we are here today to announce
enforcement actions
of historic significance this morning
the department filed criminal charges in
new york against the goldman sachs group
and its malaysian subsidiary charging
each with conspiracy to violate
the anti-bribery provisions of the
foreign corrupt practices act
these charges stem from goldman sachs's
central role
in a massive global scheme to loot
billions of dollars
from the government-run malaysian
investment fund
known as 1mdb and the subsequent use of
those funds
by senior goldman bankers and their
co-conspirators
to pay billions of dollars in bribes to
senior government officials
around the world goldman sachs malaysia
pleaded guilty to those charges just a
short while ago
and its parent entity the goldman sachs
group
has entered into an agreement with the
department of justice deferring
prosecution on those charges
for three years provided certain
conditions are met
in a reflection of the seriousness of
the bank's conduct
today's resolution includes the largest
monetary penalty
ever paid to the united states in a
corporate criminal
foreign bribery resolution and requires
the bank
to pay a total of over 2.9
billion dollars in criminal fines
penalties
and disgorgement 1mdb was a
multi-billion dollar investment fund
created by the malaysian government to
promote economic development
in 2012 and 2013 goldman received
approximately
600 million dollars in fees an unusually
large amount
for its work helping one mdb raise 6.5
billion dollars by issuing and selling
bonds on the international market
however billions of dollars were later
stolen from 1mdb
some of which was then used to bribe
corrupt officials
in malaysia and abu dhabi as well as
others
these criminal proceeds were laundered
through the united states and other
financial institutions
and used to make extravagant purchases
around the world
including high-end real estate yachts
art
and other luxury goods as the bank
admitted in court today
senior goldman bankers have played a
central role in this scheme
conspiring with others to siphon off
approximately 2.7
billion dollars from one mdb they then
use those funds to line their own
pockets
and to pay approximately 1.6 billion
dollars
in bribes in addition to the involvement
of several senior goldman executives
other personnel at the bank allowed this
scheme to proceed
by overlooking or ignoring a number of
clear
red flags now today's resolution is
significant
it includes criminal charges against the
bank and a guilty plea
by its malaysian subsidiary it also
requires goldman to disgorge
the entirety of its 600 million dollar
profit
pay a 2.3 billion dollar penalty
and admit wrongdoing in short it imposes
serious consequences
that reflect the central role that
goldman and its employees played
in this serious scheme today's charges
and guilty plea are the culmination of
years of work
by the department of justice's criminal
division the u.s attorney's office for
the eastern district of new york
the fbi's international corruption unit
and the
internal revenue services criminal
investigation
service this resolution marks a major
milestone in our efforts to fight
foreign corruption
involving u.s businesses as i mentioned
it involved 1.6 billion dollars in
bribes
which to our knowledge is the largest
amount of bribes ever paid by a company
in violation of the fcpa those bribes in
turn
resulted in 2.7 billion dollars in
losses to 1 mdb
which to our knowledge is the greatest
loss amount ever charged in an fcpa
matter
those bribes also ensured that goldman
sachs received approximately
600 million dollars in fees which to our
knowledge
is one of the largest profits ever
secured by a company
through foreign bribery in violation of
the fcpa
now as i mentioned in recognition of the
seriousness of this misconduct
today's resolution involves the largest
monetary penalty
ever paid to the united states in
connection with a corporate
criminal foreign bribery resolution
now beyond numbers this case is also
significant because it involved a
massive
corruption scheme carried out by
executives of a preeminent american bank
that caused significant harm that harm
was born principally and in the first
instance
by the people of malaysia who saw a fund
created to benefit them
and for which they remain financially
responsible instead turned into a piggy
bank
for corrupt public officials and their
cronies
the scheme also undercut confidence in
that then malaysian government
and allowed billions of dollars in
tainted funds to move through the u.s
and global financial systems the u.s is
home to many of the world's preeminent
financial institutions
as today's charges and guilty plea show
the department of justice
will not hesitate to hold them
accountable for harm
that they cause here and abroad
now today's resolution is just the
latest action that the department of
justice has taken
to hold wrongdoers accountable for and
to assist victims of
the 1mdb scheme in addition to date to
today's charges and plea
involving goldman sachs the department
has announced charges against three
individuals
in connection with this corruption
scheme including two
goldman executives one of those
executives
a former participating managing director
of the bank
and chairman of its southeast asian
operations has already
pleaded guilty the other a former
managing director
and head of investment banking for
goldman sachs malaysia
awaits trial in march of next year the
third
a foreign national remains a fugitive
from justice
now the allegations against these latter
two individuals are of course just that
allegations unless and until they are
proven guilty beyond a reasonable doubt
but these individual prosecutions
together with
the significant resolution that we are
here announcing today
demonstrate the department's steadfast
commitment to punishing corporate
misconduct
by prosecuting not only responsible
corporations
but also responsible individuals where
appropriate
i would also like to note that the
department's involvement in the 1mdb
matter
has not been limited solely to criminal
prosecutions
it began more than four years ago when
in the largest collection
of civil forfeiture actions ever brought
by the department
we filed civil suits that collectively
sought to recover
more than 1.5 billion dollars in assets
connected
with this scheme the department's work
has led to the identification
and forfeiture of over 1.1 billion
dollars
in assets traceable to 1mdb of that
the department of justice has already
returned or assisted malaysia in
recovering
more than 620 million dollars and we
expect that many millions more
will be returned to malaysia in the
months and years ahead
these forfeiture efforts were led by the
criminal division's money laundering and
asset recovery section
in partnership with our colleagues in
the u.s attorney's office
for the central district of california
the fbi
and the irs they were also made possible
through
our cooperation with partners in
switzerland
singapore luxembourg malaysia and the
united kingdom
and i would like to thank these partners
for their help and assistance
with these with this case now today's
case is also important
because of the unprecedented cooperation
and coordination
that made it possible today's resolution
includes crediting of goldman's parallel
resolutions
with no fewer than nine other u.s and
foreign authorities
the largest number ever in a foreign
bribery case
and several of those cooperating and
coordinating authorities are here with
me today
beyond sheer numbers this unprecedented
coordination
is notable for two additional reasons
first it shows that criminals cannot
escape responsibility
simply because their misconduct spans
jurisdictions and law enforcement
authorities
the department of justice and its
partners here in the u.s and across the
world
will work in parallel to investigate and
prosecute
fraud and corruption no matter where it
occurs
second it demonstrates that the
department will ensure
that fraud and corrupt conduct is
punished appropriately and seriously but
not
unfairly where companies work in good
faith
to facilitate a coordinated resolution
in a case such as this
we will do our part by avoiding piling
on
and not imposing duplicative fines or
penalties
finally i would like to note that this
case was investigated and prosecuted
at least in part during a global
pandemic it is a tribute to our team and
our partners that they overcame this
challenge
and work diligently to resolve this case
as this resolution shows the criminal
division and the department of justice
remain open for business let me end by
returning to an earlier point
the american financial system and our
american financial institutions
are the envy of the world we have a duty
to ensure
that they remain free from corruption
and that their considerable influence
and power
is used for good not to harm others
the one mdb fund held tremendous promise
for the malaysian people
but instead of realizing on that promise
it was looted by corrupt officials
and their co-conspirators including the
goldman sachs bankers that we have
charged
this criminal conduct is antithetical to
good government
it hurts free markets it undermines the
rule of law
it creates an unlevel playing field and
it puts our national security at risk
by enabling corrupt regimes around the
world
it also erodes global confidence in our
american financial institutions
and the u.s financial system today's
resolution
coupled with the other actions the
department has taken over the last
several years in connection with this
case
represent a major step towards restoring
that confidence
and making the people of malaysia whole
it imposes
serious consequences on goldman for the
bank's involvement
in this serious misconduct thank you
very much for being here today
and i would like to next turn the podium
over at least virtually to my colleague
acting u.s attorney seth ducharme in new
york thank you
thanks very much brian uh good afternoon
everyone
uh it's good to see you all uh today my
name is stephanie
i'm only acting the united states
attorney for the eastern district of new
york
and today i'm joined by
phil sweeney my left who's the assistant
director in charge of the fbi
for the new york field office uh and my
team here in brooklyn jackie casual it's
alex smith and andrew rowell
who stand beside me as well today's
resolution of
criminal charges against goldman sachs
and its malaysian
subsidiary stands in part for the
principle
that u.s federal law has a very long arm
when it comes to holding accountable
those who unfairly
tilt the scales in international
business
through the use of bribes we look far
and wide
in this investigation we uncovered
conduct as far away as malaysia
and abu dhabi that ran afoul of our u.s
criminal code
in particular the foreign practices act
we also looked in our own backyard just
a couple of miles across the brooklyn
bridge
from where we're now standing for the
new york financial district
and we there discovered that goldman
sachs and some of its senior managers
were involved in bribery and we took
appropriate action
enforcing the fcpa is a mission with
which our office is very familiar
as we have recently in other matters
here we once again
enforce the statute to help stamp out
international corruption
and to maintain the integrity of our
iconic
american financial institutions
in so doing we apply the rule of law to
the offenders evenly and fairly
consistent with the principles of
federal prosecution
whoever the offenders wherever we may
find them
the corporations as well as to
individuals
to be clear this case isn't just about
what happens in malaysia
although that is very important because
that's where the injury was done
this case is also about the way our
american
financial institutions conduct business
and it's about reminding people
where the boundaries to fair play are
there are certain lines which if crossed
carry
significant penalties and justly so
the conducted issue in this case
involved the bribery and corruption
scheme
that spanned years multiple transactions
multiple countries multiple officials
and it involved a revered new york based
bank goldman
sachs this was a scheme that helped
goldman sachs
make hundreds of millions of dollars in
fees by using bribes to incentivize
foreign officials to allow governments
accessing the bond deals
that were supposed to support energy
development in malaysia
a state-owned strategic investment fund
in malaysia one mdb's intended purpose
was to help secure the long-term
economic future
of the malaysian people but much of it
never did
instead billions of dollars were
diverted
from the 1md big bond transactions and
used to enrich the co-conspirators
and to pay the bribes and to line
goldman sachs
own pockets in the pockets of its
confederates
through the promise and payment of well
over one
billion dollars in bribes goldman sachs
obtained lucrative business from one mvp
including a role on three bond offerings
that raised approximately 6.5
billion dollars for one mvp
and earned goldman sachs over 600
million dollars in fees and revenue
even in the world of international
finance those are big numbers
and when fees like that are obtained
through violations of u.s
law they require a response from u.s
authorities
to deter similar conduct to provide just
punishment
and to level the playing field for
honest
parties the scheme was principally
carried out
by senior officials in goldman sachs and
as you know we've charged individuals in
connection with misconduct
one has pleaded guilty one awaits trial
and a third is
for the moment not within our custody
we're here today because goldman sachs
group and goldman sachs malaysia
have now accepted responsibility
for their roles in the scheme as brian
noted
goldman sachs malaysia has pled guilty
to conspiring to violate the fcpa
and the goldman sachs group has entered
into a deferred prosecution agreement
admitting its role in the conspiracy
violate the fcpa and
to pay a criminal penalty of more than
2.9 billion dollars
with over 1.2 billion dollars being paid
to the united states
today's criminal charges brought against
one of the world's largest
global investment one that is
headquartered just miles from where
i'm now standing demonstrate that we
take
this conduct seriously that we remain
steadfast in our commitment
to investigate and prosecute
white-collar criminals
both here and abroad and to hold our
financial
institutions accountable to the rule of
law
i'd now like to turn the podium over to
my colleague
bill sweeney from the fbi bill
thank you seth and thanks for the
exceptional work that your team
performed
when government officials and business
executives
secretly work together behind the scenes
for their own illegal benefit
and not that of their citizens for
shareholders their behavior lends
credibility to the narrative
the businesses do not succeed based on
the quality of the products
but rather their willingness to play
dirty greed is not good
greed like this eventually exacts an
immense cost on society
and unchecked corrupt behavior erodes
trust in public institutions
and government entities alike when greed
leads to activity that breaks federal
law
fbi professional legals will do their
part to hold the corrupt executives
officials and businesses accountable
today's announcement shows
the latest step to achieve justice in
this case
the story of 1mdb is an intricately gleb
of corruption
involving one of the world's largest
investment banks and a series of
high-level government officials overseas
senior leaders of goldman sachs picked
more than 1.6 billion in bribes to
foreign officials in malaysia and abu
dhabi
in order to cure business from one mvp
this effectively secured the position as
the lead arranger
for three bond issuances for the company
when these bonds sold
goldman charged commission fees that far
exceeded the business norm
earning them a whopping 600 million and
simultaneously
boosting their business reputation
across southeast asia
misappropriated money from this scheme
traveled around the world
two goldman sachs employees have been
charged for the role in the
international public corruption scheme
tim leicester the former southeast asian
chairman of the goldman sachs
pleaded guilty to conspiring to launder
money and conspiring to violate the fcpa
roger ong the former managing director
of goldman
and the head of investment banking for
goldman sachs malaysia
has been charged with conspiring to
launch your money and to violate the
fcpa
he finishes trial next year today we are
holding a major u.s financial
institution accountable for violations
of fcpa related practices
goldman sachs has agreed to pay more
than 2.9 billion
in criminal penalties and discouragement
fees
this case represents the largest ever
penalty
paid to the u.s authorities and if our
corrupt practice is that case
our investigation into the looting of
funds from the fdb remains ongoing
and if anybody has information that
could assist the case please call us at
1-800
call fbi this resolution of this case
would not have been reached
without the joint commitment of our law
enforcement partners here in the united
states
and overseas to include those in
singapore
switzerland united kingdom luxembourg
and of course malaysia i wanted to thank
you and thank your team
and thank the department and i'll turn
it back over to brian
thank you bill and thank you seth i'm
glad you were able to join us
from new york uh and i wanted to echo uh
bill's thank you
um to our international partners who
have assisted in this case
uh as well as to the team uh in new york
under the leadership of seth and bill
and the rest of our partners at the fbi
and the u.s attorney's office
who have been so integral to this case
with that i will turn it over now to
stephanie avakian
who is the director of enforcement at
the u.s securities and exchange
commission
thank you
thanks brian good afternoon and thank
you
i'm stephanie avakian director of the
sec's division of enforcement
today the sec announced charges against
goldman sachs for violating
the anti-bribery books and records and
internal control provisions
of the foreign corrupt practices act
goldman sachs agreed to settle the
charges and was ordered to pay a civil
penalty
of 400 million dollars the company was
also
ordered to pay discouragement of more
than 600 million dollars
which has been satisfied by the payments
the company made
to the government of malaysia and 1mdb
in a related settlement
my law enforcement colleagues here have
already described the facts of this case
so i'm not going to do it again
i will however note that from our
perspective this case highlights
the continuing need for public companies
to understand
who they are doing business with as well
as to have controls
that are tailored to the risks presented
by employees at all levels
including senior employees this is
particularly important where
as here the transactions at issue
involve billions of dollars of corporate
assets
this case also demonstrates our
long-standing and productive working
relationships
with the department of justice and other
domestic and international
regulatory and criminal authorities here
the sec staff brought to bear all of our
investigative skills
among them are skills in asset tracing
and analyzing bank records
and this resolution reflects on our
ability
to successfully deploy our respective
experience and expertise
while also sharing information as
appropriate across our parallel
investigations
vigorous enforcement of the fcpa is a
high priority for the sec
these cross-border investigations are
complex and they typically take
a long time to complete in most cases
many years
but combating the destructive and
anti-competitive effects
of bribery and corruption is critical to
furthering the sec's mission
of protecting investors maintaining fair
orderly and efficient markets and
facilitating capital formation
i'd like to recognize the division of
enforcement team who investigated this
case
they are eric heining and paul block of
the fcpa unit
and mark albers and martin healey of our
boston regional office
they were supervised by charles king
chief of the fcpa unit
i'd also like to thank the many law
enforcement colleagues in this matter
in particular thanks to brian rabbit and
his colleagues here in the criminal
division of the department of justice
seth ducharme and his colleagues in the
united states attorney's office for the
eastern district of new york
bill sweeney and his colleagues from the
fbi and jason gonzalez and his
colleagues from the board of governors
of the federal reserve system
and with that let me turn it over to
jason gonzalez thank you
thank you stephanie good afternoon my
name is jason gonzalez and i'm the
assistant general counsel for
enforcement
at the federal reserve board today the
federal reserve board is assessing 154
million dollar civil money penalty
against the goldman sachs group
for the firm's failure to maintain
appropriate oversight
internal controls and risk management
with respect to goldman's involvement
in a far-reaching scheme to defraud a
malaysian state-owned investment and
development company
known as one mtb in addition to this
penalty
the federal reserve is imposing a cease
and desist order directing goldman sachs
group to improve its risk management and
oversight
of significant and complex transactions
improve its anti-bribery compliance
program
and to enhance its due diligence related
to these transactions
the federal reserve regulates and
supervises goldman sachs and other large
banks
and our examiners will monitor the
bank's corrective actions on an ongoing
basis
and as the bank's regulator the federal
reserve oversees the adequacy of the
firm's risk management program
including controls over legal compliance
we are committed to taking firm action
to remedy serious deficiencies
and to hold banks accountable where
there are violations of law
in addition the federal reserve
previously prohibited from banking
three former goldman employees for their
actions on behalf of the firm
in the misconduct related to the one mdp
offerings
in march 2019 the federal reserve
prohibited former and
goldman employees tim leisner and roger
ing for their roles
in the scheme to divert bond proceeds
from the 1mdb offerings
leisner was also fined 1.4 million
dollars
in january 2020 the federal reserve also
prohibited a former goldman employee
andrea vela
for unsafe and unsound practices in
connection with the bond offerings
the federal reserve's actions send a
strong message to the banking industry
to make compliance with the law
a priority the action also highlights
the importance of banks effectively
managing
operational risk and the consequences of
failing to do so
the actions taken against goldman sachs
serve to remind us that we must remain
vigilant to protect the nation's
financial system
the federal reserve is proud to share
this responsibility with the justice
department and the sec
i want to close by expressing my
gratitude to the men and women at the
federal reserve
and each of the agencies represented
here today for their hard work and
dedication
today's action would not have been
possible without their collective
efforts
and i'd like to thank our host for
holding this conference to announce this
very important action
thank you brian
thank you to both jason and stephanie
for joining me here today and for their
remarks
um with that uh i believe uh we have
time
uh for a few questions um from folks on
the line so i will turn it over to matt
lloyd
we will now begin the question and
answer session to ask a question you may
press
star then 1 on your touchstone phone
if you are using a speakerphone please
pick up your handset before pressing the
keys
to withdraw your question please press
star then two
please note that you will be limited to
one question today and we do ask that
when you post your question
you specify who it is for now we will
pause momentarily to assemble our roster
our first question today comes from dave
michaels with the wall street journal
oh hi thanks for taking the question um
i guess this question is for the
assistant attorney general
given the record-breaking nature of this
case including the amount of the bribes
paid
and the penalties that are called for
why does the resolution not require a
guilty plea
by the parent or an indictment of the
parent as opposed to this unit in
malaysia
and uh did the justice department
consider
the collateral consequences that might
have flowed from
a guilty plea or indictment in making
the decision
not to insist on that thank you dave
i appreciate the question look in every
case we think hard
very hard about what the appropriate
resolution is both in terms of the size
of any penalties and discouragement that
we require
an entity to pay as well as the form of
the resolution um i think that if you
look
at the terms of this resolution on paper
there can be no question that this is a
serious
and significant resolution that imposes
serious
and significant consequences for the
offense and that it's
commensurate with the conduct that we've
described
in our filings just to kind of go over
some of those terms again in a little
bit more detail
i want to be clear about one thing
today's resolution
does in fact require or does in fact
charge goldman sachs the parent entity
with a criminal violation of the foreign
corrupt practices act as i mentioned
we've entered into a deferred
prosecution agreement with the parent
entity
and prosecution on those charges will be
deferred for a period of three years
provided certain conditions
are met but the the parent entity has in
fact
been criminally charged and as you point
out dave
the malaysian subsidiary of um of the
parent entity
goldman sachs malaysia has not only been
charged criminally
but has pleaded guilty to and admitted
its liability for
criminal fcpa violations and as i'll
note
you know this this scheme this scheme
all global in nature
was of course focused on malaysia and so
i think it makes
sense that the malaysian subsidiary of
goldman sachs
is the one who has been charged and pled
guilty
here today i'll also note in addition to
those charges
that we've charged as i mentioned three
individuals
with money laundering and fcpa
violations
in connection with their roles in this
scheme so there's been a significant
amount of criminal liability
imposed in this case criminal liability
that we we feel
is serious and significant but also
appropriate under the circumstances
and also just mention the financial
component of this resolution
as well which i also think speaks to the
the seriousness and significance of it
um goldman sachs is being required to uh
disgorge
uh and return to malaysia 100 of the
fees that it uh
earned in connection with this work and
it is also being required to pay
a global uh criminal monetary penalty
of approximately 2.3 billion dollars
which is
four times the amount of profits that it
earned in connection with this deal
in addition to that it is also entered
into a separate settlement i understand
with
malaysia whereby it will pay malaysia up
to 2.5 billion dollars so
i think considered as a whole dave the
the um
resolution here today is a serious one
it's a significant one
and it imposes meaningful consequences
for the conduct
that we've charged here today
next question
our next question comes from mike
balsamo with the associated press
thanks brian maybe you could just um
speak a little bit more about kind of
the significance of one mdb
investigations and
um you know kind of the the assets and
the work that the department
has put into um these investigations
kind of going forward including the
prosecution of
joe lowe though you know i guess it kind
of stands a reason
of whether or not the department knows
where he is and you know
uh will actually you know kind of bring
him to
court in the u.s thanks mike
um i i can address that um the the uh
uh one mdb case at the department of
justice as i mentioned in my remarks
is not simply criminal nature as i just
mentioned um
the criminal investigation here uh was
significant and it's resulted in charges
against goldman sachs
it's malaysian entities and three
individuals beyond that
it also has involved a significant
amount of work
on the civil side by our money
laundering and asset forfeiture
unit here in the criminal division as
well as other attorneys throughout the
department
i really do think it's significant you
know we have identified
and seized and had forfeited in excess
of one billion
dollars connected to or traceable to one
mdb
and we've already returned or assisted
malaysia in recovering approximately
620 million dollars that's that's money
that will go back to the people of
malaysia
and will be used uh to make good on the
debt that one mdb
incurred in connection with this scheme
and in addition to that 620 million
dollars
we expect as i mentioned that many many
millions more uh will be going back to
malaysia
in the months and years ahead as the
individual prosecutions as i mentioned
one individual a senior goldman sachs
banker the chairman
of goldman's southeast asian operations
has already pleaded guilty to criminal
charges in connection with this case
another who is a managing director and
the head of investment banking
for goldman sachs malaysia is facing
trial in march
of 2021 and we look forward to that
trial and we're preparing for it
as i mentioned earlier that individual
is innocent until proven guilty
but we will be going to trial in march
of next year and as to the third
individual as as seth
and i both mentioned he's a fugitive
from justice and and here at the
department generally speaking
we aggressively pursue fugitives and uh
we pursue
uh every avenue available to us to get
them back here to the united states
where they can face where they can in
fact face justice
for their actions thanks next question
our next question comes from kadeem
shuber with the financial times
hi there thank you for taking the
question um this is for
the assistant attorney general um you
had said in your remarks that you know
other personnel who haven't been charged
at goldman
allowed skin for seed by overlooking or
ignoring a number of clear clear red
flags um could you talk a little bit
more about what the
charges today say about um
what you sort of referenced there in
terms of overlooking or ignoring red
flags by other personnel
sure and thank you for the question look
we've been very clear here at the
department of justice
about the central role that corporate
compliance programs play
uh in corporate america today it's
something that
we take into account uh in the course of
our investigations
it's something that we take into account
and look at very seriously in connection
when
uh with resolutions of particular cases
uh here uh one factor in our analysis
was the fact that not only was their
criminal conduct
by a number of goldman sachs executives
but there was also a number of red flags
that were raised
over the course of the years that that
would have and should have allowed
goldman sachs
to either identify this conduct and
follow up on it or or stop it all
together either at the
outset or at some point before the
scheme was
completed so i think today's resolution
shows companies the importance of
corporate compliance programs
it ensures or it shows companies that
they need to ensure that their
corporate compliance programs are not
only adequate on paper
but that they're also adequately
resourced and that they're functioning
uh properly that they're tested and that
they can actually identify
uh stop and mitigate the type of conduct
that led to these significant criminal
charges
and this significant resolution with the
bank today
i think we have time for one more
question
our next question will come from felix
salmon with axios
uh thanks very much um i i was just
wondering a very simple question if you
could
um sort of add up and deduplicate some
of the
signs here it seems that if the
2.9 billion that you your headline
number 600 million if that is included
in the 2.5 billion that was paid to
malaysia there was also
350 million paid to hong kong i'm a bit
unclear about the 150 million that's
going to the fed and the 1.4 billion
that
in assets that were also sent back to
malaysia
is there a sort of bottom line number
here for the total amount of money that
goldman sachs is paying globally to set
all these charges
there is and i apologize math is not
necessarily my
my strong suit which is why i'm a lawyer
but um
i will say the global uh amount of money
that is going to be paid by goldman
sachs
in connection with the resolution that
we are announcing today
is 2.921 billion dollars
and i'll highlight just a couple of
components of that
for you but if you would like to follow
up with our office of public affairs
i'm sure we could give you a fact sheet
that breaks that down in a little bit
more detail
as well i would refer you to our filings
in the case which provide a bit more
detail about
the specific breakdown in terms of the
money but of the 2.921
billion dollars in global penalties um
606 million is being credited to
malaysia as disgorgement
the doj will be paid 1.263
billion dollars in a criminal monetary
penalty the sec
as stephanie mentioned earlier will
receive 400 million dollars
in a civil monetary penalty the fed
will receive 154 million dollars
in terms of a penalty um and then there
are a number of other foreign regulators
that are also receiving uh similar
amounts in terms of penalties
all of which is being credited against
the top line
2.9 billion dollar number
so just to again circle back the global
amount that we are announcing
in connection with today's resolution is
2.921
billion dollars of that 2.315 billion
represents penalties uh and of that
1.263 billion dollars
will be paid directly to doj which as i
mentioned is to our knowledge
the largest criminal monetary penalty
ever paid to the department of justice
in connection with a criminal foreign
bribery resolution
so with that i will close the press
conference i want to say thank you very
much to everybody for being here today
i want i want to once again thank our
team here at the department of justice
for their uh excellent work on this case
and i also want to thank our partners
here in the united states
and abroad uh for their steadfast
cooperation and coordination
as we worked to secure justice
for the united states and the people of
malaysia thank you
you